[Music]
last night I showed you how the left ate
up another potential racial situation
ended up being a racial hoax we think
this one from Georgia state lawmaker
Erika Thomas now after they're dishonest
spin fell apart when Thomas's alleged
harasser Eric sparks turned out to be a
Cuban Democrat doesn't like Trump or
Republicans part of the anti-trump
resistance well it turns out Thomas
changed her story but yesterday
Thomas changed her story back again if
you're confused over way I want to make
sure that everyone knows that it anyway
am i backtracking on my statement or am
i retrack don't weigh anything that I
said it's when he said and made a
reference to go back where you came from
he said it right after he said no I know
you people you're ignorant after that he
kept berating me and harassing me and
that's when I said and you can see from
when the cameras will be put out from
Publix I pointed to the door and after
he said go back I said you go back none
of this should come as any surprise
given Thomas's history she wants on
ironically called herself Jessie small
its hashtag biggest fan just over a year
ago Thomas portrayed another slight this
time reportedly at the hands of hotel
employees at the pool at the Westin and
after the waitress asked the Caucasian
people on both sides of me for their
order and skipped over me minutes later
the pool boy asked me for my room key
this cannot be real right now I am a
guest - right hashtag racist was this
true and possible to prove but that's
kind of the point
you see Thomas is a member of what we
call Generation G or the grievance
generation they are the product of
decades of leftist control of our
schools our entertainment industry and
they're breeding a culture of resentment
and envy basically a society of victims
and the victims no matter what are
always right here now to discuss Candace
Owens founder of the blech soup movement
and former DNC comms director Luis
Miranda great to have you both here
tonight Candace Thomas is
completely to blame here there's a
Democrat and media complex that all too
often rewards this it is a kind of a
grievance culture I mean generation G
we're here about Generation Y and X but
gosh there's a lot of grievance out
there that's kind of unprovable the
underlying allegations right you know in
many ways she is a victim of the culture
and I've said this over and over a time
over and over again ad nauseam which is
just that victimhood has become almost a
mental plague upon black America in
particular because that word racism is
being so overused that society is
becoming desensitized to it and we
actually can't even recognize it when it
actually exists we think everything is
racist things that used to be normal
conflicts between human beings getting
cut off while you're driving having a
bad correspondence in a grocery store
you should just brush it off shrug it
off and move on with your day now people
are crying and making videos and
pleading on Facebook to say look what I
experienced today I mean it's sad for
her but I think it's also says as you
mentioned earlier it's something bigger
that's happening in culture that needs
to be addressed before it goes too far
lluís the individual who she accused
seems like it really doesn't like Trump
he's a Democrat is Cuban he's not a
white man what are your thoughts on how
this all went down well he's easily the
worst person in this story and he's
someone who looks at a pregnant woman in
front of him and decides to insult her
and by his own admission calls her a
lazy sob there's probably a tinge of
racism there I can't believe that he
would call her a lazy sob if he didn't
have some of that but the media
certainly overplayed this but none of
that absolves the fact that this course
in our country has course and way too
much that there's way too much racial
tension if he did tell her to go back
and use another line it's understandable
that she may have misunderstood that
based on the incredible tension that we
have in the discourse that we have right
now about these racist things that
Donald Trump uses for political gain so
that's definitely the the an underlying
problem but at the end of the day I
think that the bad person in this story
is really this man who instead of seeing
a pregnant here's a jerk how many times
do all of us in the course of maybe a
week have something happen where
someone's sliding us or someone's saying
so they're cutting off that's happened
to me too - it's probably cutting with a
mem
I got three kids in the car millimeter
away from me
and then saying I could look for any can
you insult a black person without being
a racist that's just a question I think
the minute that he went with lazy he was
people are lazy no no it is not I've
actually I've never been called lazy my
entire life why does the word call no no
I'm asking a question
I asked you a question you said that
lazy makes you think of black people
that's what you're saying that is a
common racist truck so that's that's
within you not trying to move the ball
because you just accidentally called
black people lazy is a word that means
that you're not doing a lot all that you
ever gotta stop guys that's getting the
skin too huh okay but I think this does
go to the point that we should be able
to have bad days and people should be
able to make mistakes and he probably
made a mistake and was really rude to
her and he admitted it that doesn't mean
he's written maybe he is maybe I no one
can know but the point is the second an
allegation goes on a Facebook live
whoever makes it I don't care was a
conservative or a liberal or someone in
between it's instantly picked up if it's
validating a progressive worldview that
instantly picked up got Eric Liu goes on
TV congressman we had people on
television pundit swaying and you see
this is what Trump's caused and I think
he he seemed to be saying go to the neck
go back to the other aisle so now go
back to the other aisle is go back to
your country I mean which changed your
story it's more careful with anything
that goes viral
a lot of the discussions that we have on
this very show are a grievance culture
in and of itself just by the other
perspectives so the reality is is that
we have a culture that is incredibly
guided that the debate is coarsened and
you either have a grievance on this side
or you have it on that side and at the
end of day what you have to do is you
know I think of dr. Martin Luther King's
call too
you can't drive out darkness with
darkness you have to drive it out with
light and and that's where we have to
move the country forward is that we're
not attacking
in this way where somehow these kinds of
confrontations become normal the police
confrontation that you saw earlier
unacceptable again the lack of respect
that we talked about on the angle
tonight this has been this is not
something to happen overnight we saw
what happened during the Obama years
before Obama during Bush during Reagan
before that going all the way back to
the late 1960s and you go back and you
watch that raw footage of that that
police versus the protesters or they
were bad actors on both sides of that in
the dance and the DNC
that was I mean very long ago that's
when it all kind of disrespect cuts
across many levels of our society and it
kind of ends up where people feel afraid
like I know afraid to say anything they
don't want to share a thought because
someone will take it the wrong way they
don't want to it's that they're free to
say their opinion on anything that's
also not a good place to be
Candice I know you've been through well
so we have breaking news Candice just
gave us this news sorry I forgot you
were blocked tonight speaking of maybe
aoc thought you disrespected her you
disrespected a OC yes I couldn't let her
do that you've clearly said yes I'm like
I called her an intellectual coward
because she sets a lot of things and she
throws a lot of insults and yet she will
not debate anybody she doesn't want to
debate people on the opposite side of
the aisle and I think that if you
actually believe what you believe you
would be happy to sit down and have a
discussion in a dialogue with somebody
to get to the core of whose ideas are
better and I don't believe that she
believes anything that she says beyond
getting clicks and getting retweets I
believe though is I disagree I thought
she believed do because why not just
show up and have a debate oh maybe not
debate someone yeah well maybe she's not
very comfortable in debate but I think
she actually she's a she calls everyone
racist yeah that's unfortunately that's
that that kind of ends the conversation
it does instantly and it's unfortunate
we have to be able to just call somebody
lazy you have to be able to just say
awful things you have to be able to be
in a bad marriage okay you know I I
don't agree with a lot but I might block
you too after this conversation because
I'm just kidding on that one but the
reality is is that the debate has gotten
way too coarse and we need to change it
and I think Democrats if they're gonna
beat Donald Trump in November of next
year we can't fall into the same type of
rhetoric that we're trying
fight on the on the Republican side
whether it's about Ivanka or Kellyanne
or anybody else oh yeah guys we gotta go
we're up against the heartbreak thank
you so much panel